les républicains est donc candidat à
l'investiture pour la mairie de
marseille bonjour bruno gilles bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin on va
bien sûr longuement parlé de marseille
mais avant ça qu'est-ce que quelques
questions d'actualité cette colère
étudiante ans qui monte
après l'immolation de l'un d'entre eux
des étudiants qui dénoncent leur
précarité galerie à la taille va les
recevoir ce matin en urgence à la
demande du premier ministre
est ce que vous trouvez que le
gouvernement prend la mesure de la
situation on verra le gouvernement à
agir assez rapidement et je pense que
c'est assez logique
ce qui va prendre la mesure de ce
problème on verra ce que le gouvernement
va proposer ce une vraie détresse
une vraie détresse étudiante une vraie
détresse de la jeunesse qui aboutit à ce
drame à ce souci d' il faut il faut
quand même prendre du recul sur sûr ça
arrivait à ce qu'un étudiant se suicide
pour les conditions dramatiques dans
lesquelles aujourd'hui et les étudiants
vie vive
on le voit partout il faut un budget
assez important que ces étudiants n'ont
pas les bourses sont complètement
dépassés aujourd'hui le système des
bourses est sans doute complètement
revoir
on ne peut pas compter que que sur la
famille que sur les amis que sur les
petits boulots
aujourd'hui un étudiant en france
devrait se consacrer quasiment
exclusivement à ses études c'est pas le
cas il faut qu'ils galèrent tous les
jours pour arriver à survivre
et puis dans le côté presque
accessoirement je dirais quelquefois
s'occuper de ses études avoir la tête au
travail à la réussite ça fait beaucoup
de choses et je pense que le
gouvernement effectivement doit prendre
la mesure de ce drame autre colère c'est
celle du personnel hospitalier en
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui
agnès buzyn qui doit annoncer des
mesures dans les prochains jours quelle
va être la priorité selon vous il était
temps que le gouvernement l'a aussi
s'intéresse à ceux à ce dossier il ya
quasiment une dizaine d'années
maintenant pour par remonter plus loin
et pour parfaire la génèse des 35 heures
par exemple dans les hôpitaux qui a été
une catastrophe pour l'hôpital public et
même l'hôpital privé
aujourd'hui la ministre de la santé doit
prendre en compte ce problème là et
regardez ce qui se passe au sénat on est
en plein dans l'étude du projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale
on devait terminer le 19 novembre et le
gouvernement nous dit on va faire des
annonces le vert sur l'hôpital
c'est franchement excusez moi
l'expression se du monde et se
vraiment de la représentativité
me dis que ça sera fait avant la
nouvelle lecture du projet dont
franchement c'est pas considérer le
sénat alors vous savez très bien on a
fait ce qu'on appelle un renvoi en
commission pour gagner un petit peu de
temps et que le gouvernement puisse
faire des annonces et peut-être fassent
des annonces et des propositions pendant
l'étude du projet de loi de finances de
la sécurité sociale
en tout cas là aussi il est urgent il
faut voir sur le terrain moi je suis
vice-président du conseil de
surveillance de l'assistance publique
des hôpitaux de marseille
il faut voir la détresse des tresses en
termes bien évidemment de personnel la
détresse aussi en termes techniques
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux sont archi
archi endetté une des solutions mais le
gouvernement va peut-être le proposer ça
serait de dire on reprend la dette au
niveau de l'état pour redonner l'éclat
des cas là c'était la solution sinon on
n'y arrivera pas imaginer je ne veux pas
parler que des hôpitaux publics de
marseille mais ça fait nous disant qu'on
a reconstruit une maternité qui est
quasiment plus sains et à la maternité
du service public de l'hôpital public de
la deuxième ville de france c'est
quasiment 50 % des accouchements à
marseille c'est un sujet qui doit être
traité par le gouvernement on peut pas
chaque fois reculé et aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment des mesures important
palier du sénat icône sénat va faire
quelque chose pour répondre à la colère
des personnels hospitaliers
oui c'est un scoop que je vais vous
donner cet après midi à l'unanimité de
la commission des affaires sociales tous
les membres quelle que soit leur
appartenance politique
sur proposition de notre président alain
milon nous avons décidé de recevoir une
délégation du personnel qui manifestent
dans la rue pour les écouter pour leur
montrer que le sénat est à l'écouté des
territoires a les coudées mer à l'écouté
de la population et je pense que tous
les élus qui composent cette commission
font un joli geste un geste de
démocratie aux citoyens de recevoir et
de pouvoir ensuite faire passer leur
message et expliquer sans doute à la
ministre en direct
quelles sont les préoccupations qu'elle
connaît bien évidemment contiendront
après midi au sénat ils viennent
d'ailleurs manifesté officiellement au
cenou devant le sénat et puis nous les
recevrons et je pense que c'est un geste
fort de les recevoir et le sénat dans sa
totalité dans sa globalité sonore de
recevoir ces manifestants on va passer à
un autre sujet
parlez à votre casquette de candidat à
la mairie de marseille il ya une réunion
avait lieu hier au siège des
républicains vous êtes candidat vous
n'êtes pas le seul dans votre camp il ya
martine vassal la présidente du
département et de la métropole la
réunion qui avait lieu hier avait pour
but de trancher cette candidature ou au
moins de trouver un accord comment s'est
passée la réunion la réunion elle-même
s'est bien passée c'était une réunion
dite de conciliation le terme le terme
était peut-être un petit peu un petit
peu fort en tout cas la volonté de notre
président christian jacob et du
président de la commission nationale
d'investitures rex outils c'était
c'était de nous écouter de pouvoir
sentir un peu un peu l'ambiance
y'a pas de problème particulier et
personnel avec martine ensemble nous
connaissons depuis depuis longtemps
après il ya des différences de fond
moi je pars du principe que elle préside
déjà le département elle préside déjà la
métropole c'est déjà de grosses
responsabilités ça me paraît
incompatible avec une casquette de
candidates et si des électeurs lui font
confiance
demers aujourd'hui les marseillaises et
les marseillais est d'ailleurs tous les
habitants de grandes villes veulent des
mères à plein temps c'est ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui à paris à lyon à bordeaux
dans toutes les grandes villes où il ya
des métropoles en garde le casque êtes
vous dit qu'elle sera mr à mi temps
c'est pas possible
comment voulez gérer la deuxième ville
de france avec les problèmes qu'on va
sans doute aborder le logement insalubre
de problèmes d'école préparer pour avoir
aussi un petit un petit regard positif
préparer les jeux olympiques de 2024 qui
ont lieu aussi à marseille et en même
temps gérer
presque une centaine de communes qui
sont dans la métropole marseillaise qui
est aujourd'hui la première métropole de
france puisque la métropole de paris ne
le grand paris ne fonctionne fait la
proposition double investiture vous à la
mairie
elle a répondu non non et c'est dommage
parce que c'était c'était une solution
de consensus et s qui avait été
d'ailleurs proposé par pendant le
président par christian jacob est
certain qu il s est même essentiel ce
qui était prévu il ya quelques tarés et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui sera soumis à la
ceni dans quinze jours exactement notre
commission nationale devra trancher
entre cette double je pense est double
investiture ou allons donner
l'investiture qu'à une seule personne
mais aujourd'hui on peut pas faire les
deux et je pense que là c'est une vraie
différence de fond c'est pas un problème
spécialement politique c'est un problème
les gosses même problème de
responsabilité d'un problème de dire un
moment il faut s'occuper les
marseillaises et les marseillais bon
candidat
vous avez proposé vous a proposé elle a
fait des propositions
sinon il n'y a pas spécialement de deux
propositions on peut lire ici et là dans
la presse qu'on m'aurait proposé un
poste de premier adjoint un poste de
premier vice-président de la métropole
lancé m ça peut être vrai mais moi je
suis km vous imaginez bien moi je viens
une réunion de conciliation où je suis
candidat à la mairie de marseille je
vais pas ressortir les temps première
adjointe alors je donc à vous a proposé
premier adjoint aussi qu'elle vous a
proposé de conduire la liste sénatoriale
c'est vrai oui mais en fait la liste aux
sénatoriales jean claude gaudin ayant
quitté le sénat je suis le sénateur le
plus ancien maintenant des bouches du
rhône dans la majorité municipale
de fait je le conduirai sauf si je suis
maire de marseille dans ces cas là ça
sera sans doute un ami ou une ami
marseillais qui mènera cette liste mais
pas moi alors on va voir on va continuer
à parler en bien sûr de cette réunion
mais on va voir sur la table a été mené
un sondage je prends un sondage de
l'ifop qui a été commandé par votre
parti pour tester différentes
candidatures on va voir les résultats de
ce sondage avec flora sauvage on en
parle avec vous après caisse est en vue
à marseille pour le patron du parti
l'est républicain christian jacob
dans un sondage l'ifop a testé plusieurs
scénarios entre les deux prétendants à
l'investiture et l'air d'un côté la
présidente du département et de la
métropole
aix marseille martine vassal adoubé par
le maire sortant jean claude gaudin de
l'autre bruno gilles sénateur des
bouches du rhône martine vassal arrive
devant son rival quel que soit le
scénario
l'hypothèse selon laquelle la présidente
du département des bouches du rhône est
investi par le parti a l'air la place à
30% des intentions de vote au premier
tour loin devant le candidat du
rassemblement national stéphane ravier
dans le chaos bruno gilles serait tête
de liste l air il obtiendrait 25% des
suffrages
un point seulement devant le candidat du
rassemblement national en cas de
maintien des deux protagonistes dans la
course à la mairie de marseille
martine vassal conserve l avantage avec
ou sans l'investiture et l'air la
commission d'investiture doit trancher
le 27 novembre
voilà on voit un martine vassal en tout
cas dans ce sondage ifop vous me direz
c'est qu'un sondage mais est mieux placé
que vous pourquoi ne pas lui laisser la
place pour que les chances de la droite
de gagner marseille monte parce que si
les sondages faisait une élection on le
saurait et si les sondages faisait une
élection aujourd'hui jean noël guérini
ou patrick mennucci serai maire de
marseille parce que les sondages les
données largement le favori parce que
dans l'histoire on aurait eu comme
président de la république edouard
balladur on aurait eu sans doute une
deuxième fois nicolas sarkozy on aurait
eu sans doute aussi françois fillon sans
me faire une campagne électorale et les
sondages
à quatre mois des élections municipales
à marseille sur la totalité de la ville
alors comme vote sur huit secteurs faut
les prendre avec beaucoup de pincettes
ce qu'il faut regarder par contre c'est
l'évolution de ces sondages et moi je
regarde 15 juin 2019 lorsque les amis de
martine d'encenser le nom de son
association ont fait un son âge elle
était à 29
donc il y avait à l'époque 19 points
d'écart entre sa candidature est la
mienne est aujourd'hui l'écart s'est
réduit à 100 points
donc il ya une évolution qui met plutôt
favorable il reste encore quelques mois
je suis déjà candidat depuis un an donc
c'est pas les sondages qui font une
élection surtout dans une ville comme
marseille est ce que vous dites que quoi
qu'il arrive le 27 mai si tu es ce que
vous êtes confiant sur son issue
est ce que pour vous elle vous sera
favorable je sais pas il ya une
cinquantaine de membres
habituellement il ya à peu près une
trentaine de présents il y a une dizaine
aussi de deux sénateurs
cette investiture est doublement
importante pour moi c'est pas simplement
que l'investiture d'un parti politique
c'est pas simplement une étiquette
politique
d'ailleurs on gagne pas une élection
avec une étiquette politique soyons
honnêtes c'est pas dévaloriser
l'étiquette mais dans une ville comme
marseille par exemple qui est pas une
ville de droite qui est une ville de
gauche qui est une ville populaire avoir
ou non les messies tueur c'est pas ça
qui va changer la face de l'élection je
le fais pourquoi je dis cette
institution une double importance un
important c'est vrai politique mais d'un
autre côté pour moi elle est important
je dirais historique affective - ya
quarante ans que je sers ma famille
politique j'ai été depuis 1995
vingt-et-une fois en directeur de
campagne pendant président de la
fédération pour jacques chirac pour
nicolas sarkozy quatre fois pour les
municipales jean claude gaudin pour les
cantonales et législatives
il ne manquerait du temps pour que je
des listes tout moi j'ai une vraie
histoire est mon parti politique et
c'est aussi une reconnaissance que je
demande cette reconnaissance pour moi
elle est importante elle est politique
elle est historique elle est affective
c'est pour ça que je veux cette
investiture et après écoute et on verra
bien ne mettons pas la charrue avant les
boeufs dans lequel je joue on a un
rendez vous important
moi je me prépare cette ceni pour moi
cette commission dans son hall et
médecin turc
c'est comme une élection c'est le le j
-1 c'est le tour avant le premier tour
des élections municipales et je vois
tout le monde les députés les sénateurs
les personnalités politiques qui siègent
pour essayer de faire valoir bien
évidemment mais mes arguments mais vous
savez très bien ce que vous ferez si
jamais désigné le 27 vous dites je me
maintiens même sans l'investiture des
républicains
tous les deux nous avons dit la même
chose donc il est inutile aussi de ce
monde ça veut dire que quels que soient
leur nature il y aura martine vassal et
vous la méritez avoir avoir peut-être
que le avoir l'étiquette ou pas
l'étiquette fera changer de position
martin assad moi je suis candidat
pendant ce mois alors moi je suis
candidat depuis 14 mois je tiens cette
investiture
je tiens ou soutiennent ma famille
politique mais je suis pas candidat
depuis 14 mois je n'ai pas commencé à
bâtir un projet participatif je n'ai pas
demandé à des grandes personnalités
comme l'ancien champion olympique à
jackson richardson de me rejoindre pour
au dernier moment à jeter l'épongé
non moi je suis candidat lors qu'il
arrive et celle de son bilan écoutez
c'est ce que dit jean claude roux dont
celle qui est le mieux à même à porter
le bilan de la municipalité il a redit
hier soir celle qui est le mieux à même
à pouvoir faire des accords avec le
parti des manuels macron parce que c'est
ça aussi que le maire a dit a dit hier
soir c'est martin en salle donc elle
elle doit accepter aussi ce bilan -
depuis 14 mois je n'ai jamais eu un mot
un mot de travers pour jean envers jean
claude gaudin je n'ai jamais un moment à
accepter de ne pas prendre mes
responsabilités mais il ya des
différences il ya des différences jean
claude gaudin le sait je les ai exprimé
avec lui donc je vous explique chaque
fois publiquement sur la gestion du
logement salubre sur la vente du stade
vélodrome sur le ppp des écoles on peut
avoir des différences et les exprimer
proprement poliment en tout cas
lorsqu'on est effectivement soutenu par
jean claude gaudin il faut accepter de
prendre la totalité du bilan et le
mauvais alors justement un mode sur son
son bilan sur ce rapport de la chambre
régionale des comptes qui a dressé le
bilan des pratiques de l'équipe
municipale en place aussi bien sur la
situation financière qu'elle juge alors
elle parle de dépenses peu économe des
deniers publics il ya aussi le bilan sur
la gestion du personnel
là elles parlent d' irrégularités dans
les conditions de recrutement pour la
chambre régionale des comptes marseille
est dans une situation préoccupante
votre parti est à la tête de la ville
depuis 1995 est-ce que c'est pas aussi
le bilan de la droite ce bilan
catastrophique ça c'est jean claude
gaudin a bien dit qu'il allait répondre
point par point à toutes les
observations de la chambre régionale des
comptes
moi j'ai pris une décision à l'époque
politique il ya quelques semaines en
tant que candidat mais aussi en tant que
membre de la majorité municipale que
j'assume toujours je ne ferai aucun
commentaire sur ce rapport tant que le
maire n'aura pas répondu au conseil est
ce que vous ne sentez comptable de ce
million et de cette situation
aujourd'hui à écouter il ya des choses
que je les lui bien évidemment ce
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qu'il y a des reproches qui
concerne plus l'entourage parfois du
maire le cabinet et puis il ya des
reproches qui concerne les écoles qui
concerne la gestion
bien évidemment que quand on est membre
sortant du nil ses qualités il faut
assumer la facilité c'est de dire moi je
n'étais que mr des quatrième et
cinquième en y semant donc je suis
comptable que des quatrième et cinquième
en dix ans vous assumez aux en ce moment
il faut il faut être droit dans ses
bottes et pouvoir se regarder tous les
matins dans la glace
allez on va parler d'un dossier qui
inquiète particulièrement marseillan
c'est le logement vous avez travaillé
notre journaliste parlementaire alex
tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour ariane bonjour bruno g alors
alex un an après le tragique
effondrement d'immeuble rue d'aubagne
qui a fait huit morts quel bilan peut-on
faire de la lutte contre le logement
insalubre à marseille eh bien on va déjà
voir ce qui a été fait pour toutes les
victimes du logement insalubre à
marseille depuis ce drame de noailles
il ya eu 3000 personnes évacuées de
leurs logements et parmi ces 3000
personnes
on peut compter 33 % de personnes qui
ont peu ou qui ont pu retourner et
finalement dans leur logement
56 % de personnes qui ont été relogées
et toujours 11 % de personnes qui vivent
à l'hôtel
alors il s'agit également de re
construire et de rénover l'habitat
indigne à marseille
et là sur ce point il ya une action
concertée entre la ville et l'état avec
notamment un grand plan de rénovation
urbaine qui doit s'étaler sur plus de
1000 hectares 800 millions d'euros vont
être investis avec 600 millions d'euros
de fonds publics
et puis le permis de louer et
expérimenté à marseille ça veut dire
qu'un bailleur devra obtenir une
autorisation avant de pouvoir louer son
bien alors le problème de l'habitat
indigne va au delà de la ville de
marseille il concerne tout le territoire
français et sur ce point les
parlementaires se sont mobilisés pour
proposer des solutions contre ce fléau
et il a eu deux propositions de loi
déposées
d'abord l'une au sénat par vous bruno
gilles avec une proposition notamment de
créer une police spéciale du logement
pour lutter traquer les marchands de
sommeil
la seconde proposition vient de
l'assemblée nationale et du député
communiste stéphane peu qui propose
chaque année de rénover soixante mille
logements indignes sur une durée de 10
ans en tout cas pour l'instant le
gouvernement n'a pas donné d'avis
définitif sur ces propositions
merci beaucoup alex sur cette question
du logement digne est ce que vous
trouvez que le gouvernement ont fait
assez bruno gilles on va parler de la
question de marseille dans un instant
avec nos confrères de la provence ans
mais plus généralement il ya beaucoup
d'annoncés il faut aller plus loin et le
meilleur exemple est ce que ce qui vient
d'être dit ma proposition de loi a été
votée à l'unanimité au sénat
c'est très rare vous le savez et je
tiens à le souligner et je tiens
d'ailleurs à remercier le ministre du
logement mme ceux de normandie parce que
son cabinet a travaillé on a travaillé
ensemble pour avoir une proposition de
loi que c'est acceptable par tout le
monde
depuis elle n'a pas été inscrite à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
il ya un rapport qui a été fait qui a
été donnée au gouvernement par des
parlementaires de la majorité
il ya une proposition de loi qui est
fait par aussi un élu communiste qui a
aucune chance bien évidemment de passer
l'avantagent de ma proposition de loi
qui a été votée à l'unanimité au sénat
c'est donc par aussi les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle c'est qu'elle
pourrait être reprise en l'état
exactement de la même manière à
l'assemblée nationale et dans ces cas-là
si elle était votée conforme mais vous
le savez très bien qu'on va éviter
toutes les navettes ça ira vite et puis
dans ces cas on pourrait appliquer ça
serait force de loi c'est ça aussi que
j'attends du gouvernement c'est pas
simplement des des belles paroles de la
présence ya eu un soutien psychologique
un soutien politique du ministre du
logement il est venu souvent à marseille
c'est vrai et ça il faut le remercier
par bordeaux me font parler la santé
tout à l'heure on n'a jamais vu une
ministre de la santé à marseille depuis
dix ans imaginez comment ce qu'on
commence préoccupe des hôpitaux publics
de la ville de marseille le ministre est
là le ministre soutient
sauf qu'à un moment le ministre mais
quand il sort de chez qui il fau qui
signe un chèque et s'en sont beaucoup de
paroles beaucoup de présence mais de
talence des politiques mais pas d'acte
et surtout pas de financer lé puisqu'on
parle de marseille on va y aller on va
retrouver nos partenaires de la provence
bonjour j'aimerai qu'avez vous êtes le
directeur des rédactions de la prononce
on va parler en de votre journal dans
quelques instants mais d'abord vous avez
une question à poser à bruno gilles
justement sur ce sujet du logement
oui effectivement parce qu'on a bien vu
samedi que de nombreux marseillaise et
de nombreux marseillais étaient
descendus dans la rue pour dire bien sûr
leur colère sur cette question du mal
logement
il ya une thématique qui revient quand
même depuis un an et ce drame du 5
novembre à marseille
c'est que beaucoup de marchés ont le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été entendus
ne peut être pas être considéré en tout
cas par leurs élus vous vous positionnez
comment bruno gilles sur cette question
d'abord bonjour guillem rica vie moi je
me suis positionné vous le savez très
bien
il ya déjà un an on me l'a d'ailleurs
reproché parfois dans dans mes amis
politiques mêlant parfois reprocher
lorsqu'il ya eu le conseil municipal qui
a suivi le drame du 5 novembre 2018 j'ai
été le seul élu de la majorité a
présenté ses excuses au conseil
municipal
ça a été retenu par les médias ça a été
reconnu et je regrette que certaines des
amis politiques ont considéré que ses
excuses étaient un manque de solidarité
à la majorité municipale s'était pas le
cas j'ai proposé immédiatement cette
proposition de loi j'ai fait des
propositions au niveau local moi je me
suis posé sonner très vite sans aucune
volonté de récupération politique
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas allé il ya
quelques jours à la manifestation au
rassemblement qui suivait ce cet
anniversaire dramatique
ddd à nantes du drame du du du 5
novembre
après sur le terrain il ya des choses à
faire moi je continue à travailler avec
des associations je continue à
travailler avec des bailleurs sociaux je
continue à travailler avec beaucoup de
gens parce que on en a parlé je suis
candidat aux élections municipales et je
souhaite dès la fin du mois de mars 2020
des martiens me font confiance
être immédiatement opérationnel sur le
dossier du logement social
il y a des choses à faire il faut
s'appuyer sur les bailleurs sociaux il
faut s'appuyer sur la case aider sur la
filiale plutôt logement social de la
caisse des dépôts et des consignations
des propositions existent il faut
s'appuyer bien sûr sur l'aide de l'état
tout ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est
magnifique mais un moment c'est 800
millions d'euros ils sont faut aller
très vite faut commencer par le centre
ville et puis voilà on a commencé à
mettre en place le permis à louer il
faut cette police du ce pouvoir de
police du logement il faudrait qu'on y
revienne parce que je pense que c'est
important mais le terme à nos la
provence aujourd'hui m
on va voir ça avec vous d'abord cette
opération points contre les trottinettes
oui une opération coup de poing et c'est
effectivement une première puisque hier
les forces de police ont réalisé le
premier contrôle routier qui visait les
conducteurs de trottinettes place de
romière déploiement donc des services de
sécurité routière de la police
municipale pour essayer d'endiguer un
fléau qui existe dans les grandes villes
et notamment à marseille c'est la
circulation anarchique de ces
trottinette 1 vous le savez en libre
service avec dans un premier temps une
démarche de sensibilisation pendant
quelques semaines mais dans trois quatre
semaines je vous préviens si vous
circulez sur un trottoir à marseille
si vous circulez comme passager sur
votre trottinette ou alors effectivement
si vous allez trop vite un plus de 26
kilomètres heures eh bien vous aurez des
amendes et des amendes salées de 35
euros pour la plus petite à 1500 euros
pour excès de vitesse en trottinette sur
les trottoirs de marseille voilà ça peut
ça peut coûter cher et en plus c'est
dangereux il faut éviter de le faire
deuxième sujet c'est plus léger plus
glamoureux aussi c'est l'élection de
miss france elle se tiendra à marseille
dans un mois pile et c'est la première
fois depuis soixante huit ans qu'elle a
lieu à marseille
exactement c'est ça le 14 décembre les
30 miss régionales qui ont été élus
viendront défiler sous le dôme de la
coupole de saint juste c'est juste sous
le conseil départemental d'ailleurs des
bouches du rhône elles viendront donc
défilé vous allez me dire pourquoi
marseille puisque la tradition veut que
l'élection suivante se passe dans la
ville ou dans la région natale de la
miss 2018 on se souvient que la miss
2018 et haïti et à tahiti n'y a hélas
pas de salle assez grande doit d'adapter
en tout cas l'accueil d'une telle
manifestation d'un tel spectacle des
villans candidate et marseille a été
retenu la ville de marseille a
d'ailleurs alloué un budget de 150 mille
euros et donc les 30 miss vont défiler
le 14 pour désigner et bien la mise 2019
sachez toutefois que les places pour
assister à ce spectacle ont déjà toutes
été vendues en seulement une heure 4000
places vendues pour ce spectacle un peu
hors norme à domicile pour celui qu'il
présente c'est bien sûr jean pierre
foucault
merci beaucoup à y aller on imagine que
vous soutenez miss provence
on va donner son nom c'est lourd eu à
miss provence
on va voir merci viendrait calvi d'avoir
été avec nous on va continuer avec la
revue de presse de marseille alex
poussard ne rejoint et alex ont parlé de
la provence vous commencez avec cette
une de la provence qui comme beaucoup de
une de pqr et consacré raymond poulidor
mais oui la provence qui consacre sa une
à pout pout raymond poulidor la légende
du cyclisme français qui s'est éteint
hier à l'âge de 83 ans
c'était l'éternel second mais toujours
premier dans le coeur des français
et quand on lit l'éditorial de franz
olivier giesbert le patron de la
provence et bien cet amour des français
pour raymond poulidor s'exprime
s'explique par les valeurs de fair play
et de modestie qui l'incarné
et puis dans la provence on peut pas
s'empêcher de parler d' municipal et
c'est jean luc mélenchon oui oui jean
luc mélenchon qui s'invite dans la
campagne des élections municipales alors
qu'il avait dit qu'il resterait discret
qu'il n'était candidat à rien mais
finalement il va essayer de réunir les
listes de gauche et d'insoumis qui sont
candidates aux élections municipales
mais qui pour l'instant partent en ordre
dispersé on va continuer à la
marseillaise
et oui la marseillaise qui publie une
enquête sur les transactions
immobilières douteuses de la ville de
marseille selon cette enquête la mairie
de marseille aurait vendu des biens
immobiliers à des tarifs peu avantageux
au profit de personnalités sulfureuses
comme un certain jean paul di noia qui
est présenté dans cette enquête commune
ancienne figure du milieu
et puis on parle aussi de marseille dans
la presse nationale dans l'express et
oui alors qu'un radar pas comme les
autres est installé à marseille un radar
de pollution qui informe les
automobilistes sur leurs émissions
polluantes alors ce dispositif est déjà
utilisée à paris et il a révélé pour
certaines voitures car leurs émissions
étaient six fois supérieures à ce
qu'indique le constructeur l'un
terminent rapidement et marssac et oui
encore une enquête sur marseille
marsactu qui révèle que les statistiques
de la délinquance à marseille aurait été
trafiqués bidouiller il se base sur des
révélations du canard enchaîné
car il ya deux ans le ministère de
l'intérieur avait
repéré des anomalies dans les chiffres
marseillais il avait donc lancé un audit
et résultats quelques mois plus tard
c'est confirmé il assure que les
statistiques de la délinquance de la
voie publique à marseille ont bien été
minorés merci beaucoup alex bruno gilles
merci d'être venu on aura encore plein
de questions à vous poser mon imagine
que vous reviendrez municipal merci